Turkish President Recep Tayyip Erdogan delivered a speech...
...leaking information contradicting Saudi explanations...
...for the murder of Jamal Khashoggi and calling for the prosecution of anyone involved.
Vietnam lawmakers have elected Communist Party chief Nguyen Phu Trong as president...
...after a 99.8% vote in his favor, making him the only candidate on the ballot.
Hong Kong's leader announces plans to ban e-cigarettes...
...and other new smoking products to protect public health within the Chinese territory.
The Herat province in western Afghanistan faces continuing challenges...
...as terrorists and extremist groups threaten the province's security.
Finally, Chinese President Xi Jinping...
...announced the opening of the world's longest sea crossing bridge.
The 55-kilometer-long Hong Kong - Zhuhai - Macao bridge connects the three regions...
...through a tunnel complex across the Pearl River Delta.